good morning dear colleagues can i ask
you to take your seats
dear colleagues good morning
can i ask you to take your seats please
once again good morning
to all of you dear colleagues
first of all i am pleased
to welcome the president of the european
commission ursula van der lion to our
european parliament for the annual
state of the european union address
it is also very much a special honor
to have
olena zelenska with us on this important
day
[Applause]
dear elena we are with you
and with the ukrainian people we are
here today
against an alarming backdrop of an
illegal unjustifiable invasion
of sovereign ukraine
high inflation electricity and energy
price rises
a climate catastrophe
increased food insecurity and a fast
emerging
cost of living crisis
i think our message today will be that
europe
will respond
and to underline how we will do that it
is my pleasure to give the floor to the
president of the european commission to
deliver her 2022 state of the european
union at rest jerusalem the floor is
yours
[Applause]
thank you madam president
honorable members
my fellow
europeans never before
has this parliament debated the state of
our union
with war
raging on european soil
and we all remember that fateful morning
in late february europeans from across
our union
woke up
dismayed by what they saw
shaken by the resurgent and ruthless
face of evil
haunted by the sounds of sirens and the
sheer brutality of war
but from that very moment on
a whole continent
has risen in solidarity
at the border crossings where refugees
found shelter
in our streets filled with ukrainian
flags
in the classrooms where ukrainian
children made new friends
from that very moment
europeans neither hid nor hesitated
they found the courage to do the right
thing
and from that very moment
our union as a whole
has risen to the occasion
15 years ago
during the financial crisis
it took us years to find lasting
solutions
a decade later when the global pandemic
hit it took us only weeks
but this year
as soon as russian troops crossed the
border into ukraine
our response was united
determined and immediate and i think we
can be proud of that
[Applause]
we have brought europe's inner strength
back to the surface
and we will need all this strength
the moments ahead of us
will not be easy
be it for the families who are
struggling to make ends meet
or businesses who are facing tough
choices concerning their future
and let us be very clear
much is at stake
not just for ukraine
but for all of europe and the world at
large and we will be tested
tested by those
who want to exploit any kind of division
between us
and this is not only a war unleashed by
russia
against ukraine
this is also worn our energy
it's a war on our economy
it's a war on our values
it is a war on our
future it is about autocracy
against democracy
and i stand here with a conviction
that with the necessary courage
and with the necessary solidarity putin
will fail and ukraine and europe will
prevail
today
courage
has a name
and that name is ukraine
courage has a face
and that face is the face of ukrainian
men and women
who are standing up
to the russian aggression
i remember a moment in the early weeks
of the invasion
when the first lady of ukraine
olena zelenska
gathered the parents
of ukrainian children
killed by the invader
hundreds of families
for whom the war will never end
and for whom life will never go back
to what it was before
we saw the first lady
leading a silent crowd of heartbroken
mothers and fathers
and hangs small bells in the trees
one for every fallen child
and now these bells will ring forever in
the wind
and forever
the innocent victims of this war
will live in our memories
and yes she's here with us today
my dear olena zelenska
it took immense courage to resist
putin's cruelty
but you found the courage
and a nation of heroes has risen
today in ukraine stands strong because
an entire country has fought street by
street and house by house
and we are seeing in the last days the
bravery of the ukrainians is paying off
ukraine stands strong because people
like your husband president zielenski
have stayed in keith
to lead the resistance
together with you
and your children
you have given courage
to a whole nation
[Applause]
you have given a voice to your people on
a global stage
you have given hope to all of us
so today we want to thank you and all
ukrainians
glory to a country of european heroes
slava ukrainian
europe's solidarity with ukraine will
remain unshakable
from day one on
europe has stood at ukraine's side with
weapons
with funds
with hospitalities for refugees
and with the toughest sanctions the
world has ever seen
russia's financial sector is on life
support
we have cut off three quarters of
russia's banking sector from
international markets
nearly 1 000 international companies
have left the country
the production of cars fell by 75
percent compared to last year
ira flood is grounding planes because
there are no more spare parts
the russian military
is taking chips from dishwashers and
refrigerators
to fix their military hardware because
there are no semiconductors anymore
russia's industry is in tatters
and it is the kremlin
that has put russia's economy on the
path of oblivion
that is the price
for russians russia's and putin's trail
of death and destruction
and i want to make it very clear
the sanctions are here to stay this is
time for us for resolve and not for
appeasement this has to be very clear
the same is true for our financial
support for ukraine
so far team europe has provided more
than 19 billion euros in financial
assistance and this is without counting
the military support
and we are in for the long haul
ukraine's reconstruction will require
massive resources
for instance russian strikes have
damaged or destroyed more than 70
schools
half a million ukrainian children have
started their school year in the
european union but many other ukrainian
children simply do not have a classroom
to go to
and you told me yesterday dear orlando
that every day when the parents are
sending the children to school
they don't only give them the school bag
but also an emergency bag with water
with food
with band-aids
medical supply
with socks
and an underwear to change and just
imagine you send in the morning your
child to school hand back in
to school and you do not know whether
you're going to be reunited in the
afternoon after school so my dear
orlando i am announcing that we will
work with you
to support the rehabilitation of damaged
ukrainian schools we will provide what
you need this is 100 million euros
because the future of ukraine begins in
the schools and with the children
we will not only support financially but
also empower ukraine to make the most of
its potential
ukraine has already a rising tech hub
and home is home to many very young
smart companies
so i want us to mobilize the full power
of our single market to help accelerate
growth and create opportunities
please remember in march we connected
successfully ukraine to our electricity
grid it was planned for 2024 we did it
in two weeks only
and today ukraine is exporting
electricity to the european union
so i want to significantly expand this
mutual beneficial trade
we have already suspended import duties
on ukrainian exports to ukraine
we will bring ukraine into our european
free roaming area it's really time to do
that now
our solidarity lines are big success and
building on all of that
the commission will work with ukraine
to go a step further and to ensure a
seamless access to the single market of
the european union our single market is
one of europe's greatest success stories
we know the power that lies in the
single market so now it is time to make
it a success story for our ukrainian
friends too
and this is why today i'm going to keefe
to discuss all this with president
zelinski and to show him what the single
market is as a potential for ukraine's
future too
my honor remembers
one lesson from this war is
we should have listened
to those who know putin
to anna politkovskaya
and all the russian journalists
who exposed the crimes
and paid the ultimate price
to our friends in ukraine moldova
georgia and the opposition in belarus
we should have listened to the voices
inside our union in poland in the
baltics and all across central and
eastern europe
they have been telling us for years
that putin would not stop
and they acted accordingly
our friends in the baltics have worked
hard to end their dependency on russia
they have invested heavily
in renewable energy in lng terminals in
interconnected
they made the experience yes this comes
at a cost but dependency on russian
fossil fuels comes at a much much higher
price
so we have to get rid of this dependency
over all over europe
as you know therefore we agreed to join
storage we are now at 84
that's good we're overshooting our
targets
but unfortunately this will not be
enough
we have to diversify away from russia
to some reliable suppliers like the
united states and norway and algeria and
others
two figures that are interesting last
year
russian gas accounted for 40 percent
of our imported gas
today it's down to nine percent
but we also see
that russia keeps actively manipulating
our energy market
i mean they prefer to flare the gas
instead of
sending it to europe according to the
contracts that are existing so this
market is not functioning anymore
and in addition
the climate crisis is heavily weighing
in our bills
heat waves have boosted electricity
demand
droughts shut down hydro and nuclear
plants
and as a result
prices have risen by more than 10 times
compared to before the
pandemic making ends meet is becoming a
source of anxiety
for millions of businesses and
households in the european union
but
we also see how europeans are coping
with this challenge think of the workers
in ceramic factories in central italy
who have decided to move their shifts to
the early morning to benefit from the
lower energy prices and just imagine
the mothers and fathers among those
workers having to leave home early when
the kids are still sleeping because of a
war they have not chosen
this is one example in a million of
examples of europeans
adapting to the new reality
and i want our union to take example
from its people
so reducing demand
during peak hours
will make supply last longer and it will
bring prices down
this is why we're putting forward
measures for member states to reduce
their overall electricity consumption
and then
targeted support is needed for small and
medium enterprises like the glass makers
across europe who cannot longer turn on
their ovens
or for single parents facing one
daunting bill after the next if they
look at electricity
millions of europeans need support
this is why we are proposing a cap on
the revenues of companies
that produce electricity at low costs
these companies are making revenues they
never accounted for
they never even dreamt of
and don't get me wrong in our social
market economy
profits are okay they are good
but
in these times it is wrong to receive
extraordinary record revenues and
profits
benefiting from war and on the back of
our consumers
in these times
profits must be shared and channeled to
those who need it most
and therefore our proposal also
includes the fossil fuel electricity
producers who have to give a crisis
contribution
and overall our proposal will raise more
than 140 billion euros for member states
to cushion the blow directly
these are all emergency and temporary
measures we are working on including our
discussion on gas temporary measure so
on one hand we have to ensure the
security of supply
on the other hand we have to ensure
global competitiveness
the security of the apply because the
gas still has to come to the european
union the energy of all
on the other hand if it's too expensive
it's damaging our global competitiveness
so we will develop with the member
states a set of measures
to take into account the specific nature
of our relationship with suppliers
ranging from unreliable suppliers such
as russia
to reliable friends such as our
norwegian friends for example
i have agreed with prime minister store
to set up a task force
so that the teams work for this aim
together to look how are we able to
lower
in a reasonable manner the price for gas
another important topic
is on the agenda
today our gas markets have changed
dramatically
from pipeline gas we used to have an
abundance mainly to increasing amounts
of lng gas but the benchmark used in the
gas market the so-called ttf has not
adapted
so this is why the commission will work
on establishing a more representative
benchmark
for the
electricity trading that really reflects
this change in the market we have seen
and at the same time we also know that
energy companies are facing severe
problems with liquidity
in electricity futures markets
we will work with the market regulators
to ease these problems by amending the
rules on collaterals
and by taking measures
to limit the intraday price volatility
and we will amend the temporary state
aid framework in october
to allow for the provision of state
guarantees
while preserving a level playing field
this is very complex
this is not at all trivial but i must
say these are only the first steps
but because as we deal with immediate
crisis we must also look forward
and therefore
my diagnosis is the current electricity
market designed that is based on the
principle of merit order
is not fit for purpose anymore it's not
just for consumers anymore
consumers should reap the benefits
of low cost renewables
that must be the purpose so we have to
decouple
the dominant influence of gas on the
price of electricity
and this is why we will do a deep and
comprehensive
now honorable members there is one
important point
half a century ago
in the 1970s
the world faced another fossil fuel
crisis
some of us remember the car free
weekends to save energy
yet
we kept driving on the same road
we did not get rid of our defend
pendancy on oil
and worse
fossil fuels were even massively
subsidized
this was wrong
not just for the climate
but also for our public finances and for
our independence as we know today and
we're still paying the price for that
only a few visionaries understood
that the real problems
problem
was the fossil fuels themselves
not their price
and among them were our danish friends
when the oil crisis hit
denmark started to invest heavily into
harnessing the power of the wind
they laid the foundation
for its global leadership in the sector
and created tens of thousands of new
jobs
this is the way to go not just a quick
fix
but a change of paradigm a leap into the
future and that must be our principle
today with this crisis too on rubber
members
[Applause]
to completely not float voila solidarity
european on action
honourable members
the last years have shown how much
europe can achieve
when it is united
after an unprecedented pandemic
our economic output overtook pre-crisis
level in record time
we went from having no vaccines
to securing over four billion of these
life saving vaccines for europeans and
for the whole world
and in record time we came up with sure
so that people could stay in their jobs
even if their companies had run out of
work
we were in the deepest recession since
world war ii
and we achieved the fastest recovery
since the post-war boom
and all that was possible
because we all rallied
behind a common recovery plan
next generation eu
has been a boost of confidence for our
economy
and its journey has only just begun
so far
100 billion euros have been disbursed
for member states to member states
this means 700 billion euros still
haven't flown into our economy
next generation you will guarantee a
constant stream of investment to sustain
jobs and growth
it means relief for our economy
but most importantly
it means renewal
it is financing new wind turbines and
solar parks high-speed train and
energy-saving renovations
we conceived next generation eu almost
two years ago and yet
it is still exactly what europe needs
today so let's stick to the plan and
bring the money to the ground it has to
be delivered because it's necessary now
as investment
and honorable members
the future of our children
needs both
that we invest in sustainability
but also that we invest sustainable to
have to acknowledge a new reality
of higher public debt
we need fiscal rules
that allow for strategic investment
while safeguarding fiscal sustainability
rules that are fit for the challenges of
this decade
and therefore in october we will come
forward with new ideas
for our economic governance
let me share few basic principles with
you
member states should have more
flexibility
on their debt reduction path
but there should be more accountability
on the delivery
of what we have agreed on
there should be simpler rules that all
can follow
to open the space for strategic
investments we need it
and to give the financial markets the
confidence they need
so let us chart once again a joint way
forward
with more freedom to invest that's
necessary
more scrutiny on the process what has
been agreed has to be done
more ownership by member states and
better result for the citizens so in
short
let's rediscover the mastery spirit
stability
and growth can only go hand in hand
because honorable members as we embark
on this transition
in our economy
we must rely
on the enduring values of the social
market economy
it's the beautiful simple idea that
europe's greatest strength
lies in each and every one of us
our social market economy encourages
everyone to excel
but it also takes care of the fragility
as human being
it covers the big risks of life like
poverty
sickness age
it rewards performance
and guarantees protection
it opens opportunities
but it also sets limits
and we need this today even more than
ever
because the strength of our social
market economy
will drive the green and the digital
transition
and our accolades heal
for the small and medium enterprises are
basically three things
it's do we have an enabling business
environment
it's a question do we have a workforce
with the right skills
and do we have access to raw materials
our industry needs
this will be the three crucial questions
to answer right now
to have a future
with the models as with as i've
described right now
we must for our smes remove the
obstacles that still hold them back
they must be at the center of this
transformation because they are the
backbone of our industry and europe's
long history
of industrial prowess
and they have always put their employees
first even and especially in times of
crisis
but inflation and uncertainty are
weighing especially hard on them
this is why
we will put forward
an sme relief package
it will include a proposal
for a single set of tax rules for doing
business in europe
called be fit
it will make it easier to do business in
our union
less red tape
better access to the dynamism of our
continental market
and honorable members it is high time
that we revise the late payment
directive
because it's simply not fair
that one in four bankruptcies that's 25
of all bankruptcies
are due to invoices not being paid in
time this can't be possible for millions
of family businesses we have to revise
this late payment directive this will be
a lifeline in troubled watches
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm einsabers
fast complete example
we are missing
and
[Applause]
foreign
but securing supplies
is only a first step
the processing
of these metals is just as critical
and today
china controls the global global
processing industry
almost 90 percent 90
of rare earth and 60 percent of lithium
are processed in china
so we will identify strategic projects
all along the supply chain from
extracting to refining from processing
to recycling
and we will build up strategic reserves
where supply is at risk
this is why today
i am announcing a european critical raw
materials act
we know that this approach can work
because remember
five years ago
europe launched the batteries alliance
and soon
two thirds of the batteries we need we
will produce here in europe that's a big
success story
last year i announced the european ships
act
and the first chips gigafactory will
break ground in the coming months
so we now need to replicate this success
for raw materials
and this is also why we will increase
our financial participation
in the important projects of common
european interests the so-called ipceis
and for the future
i will push to create a new european
sovereignty fund
because we have to make sure
that the future of the industry is made
in europe
honourable members
as we look around
at the state of the world today
it can often feel like
there is a fading away
of what once seemed so permanent
and in some ways
the passing of queen elizabeth ii
last week
reminded us
all of that
she is a legend
she was a constant
throughout the turbulent and
transforming events in the last 70 years
stoic
and steadfast in her service
but more than anything
she always found the right words for
every moment in time
from the call she made to war evacuees
in 1940
to her historic address during the
pandemic
she spoke not only to the heart
of her nation
but to the soul of the whole world
and when i think of the situation we're
in today
her words at the height of the pandemic
still resonate with me she said
we will succeed
and that success will belong to every
one of us
end of quote
she always reminded us that our future
is build on new ideas and founded in our
oldest values
since the end of world war ii
we have pursued the promise
of democracy and of the rule of law
and the nations of the world have built
together an international system
promoting peace and security justice and
economic progress
today
this is the very target of russian
missiles
what we saw on the streets streets of
bucha in the scotch fields of grain
and now in the gates of ukraine's
largest nuclear plant
is not only a violation of international
rules it is the deliberate attempt to
discard them once and for all that we
have to know
and this watershed moment
in global politics
calls for rethink
of our foreign policy agenda
this is to the time to invest in the
power of our democracies
this work begins with a core group of
our like-minded partners
our friends in every single democratic
nations on the globe
we see the world with the same eyes
we share the same values and we should
mobilize our collective power to shape
global goods
we should strive to expand the core of
these democracies
the most immediate way to do this is to
deepen our ties
and strengthen democracies on our
continent
this starts with those
that are already on the path to our
union
we must be at their side by every step
and every day
because the path towards strong
democracies and the path towards our
union are one and the same and so i want
to know the people of the western
balkans ukraine moldova and georgia to
know and i think i speak in the name of
this noble house
you are part of our family you are the
future of our union and in our union and
our union is not complete without you
this has to be the message
[Applause]
and we have seen that there is a need to
reach out to other countries of europe
beyond the accession process this is why
i support the call for european
political community
and we will set out our ideas to the
european council
but our future also depends on our
ability to engage beyond the core of our
democratic partners
countries near and far
share an interest in working is near and
far
such as climate change and
digitalization
and this is the main idea behind global
gateway the investment plan i announced
last year right at this place
it is already delivering on the ground
together with our african partners
we're building two factories in rwanda
and senegal to manufacture mrna vaccines
so they will be made in africa for
africa with world class technology
and we are now replicating this approach
across latin america
as a part of a larger engagement
strategy that has to pick up now
urgently
so we will team up with our friends
in the united states and our friends
in the g7 partners to make this happen
in this spirit
president biden and i will convene a
leaders meeting
to review and announce implementation
projects for this investment
honorable members
this is part of our work of
strengthening our democracies
but
we should not lose sight
of the way
foreign autocrats
are targeting our own countries
foreign entities are funding
institutions
and institutes that undermine our values
the disinformation is spreading from the
internet into the halt of our
universities
earlier this year the university of
amsterdam
shut down an allegedly independent
research center
which was actually funded by chinese
entities
and this center was publishing so-called
research on human rights
dismissing the evidence of forced labour
camps for eurygors as rumors
these lies are toxic for our democracies
and let's think about this we introduce
legislation to screen foreign direct
investment in our companies for security
reasons that's correct that's good that
we did it
but if we do that for our economy
shouldn't we do the same for our values
we need to better shield ourselves from
align interference
and this is why we will present
a defense of democracy pact
it will bring forward
covert foreign influence
it will shed the light
on
shady funding
we will not allow any autocracies
trolling horses to attack our
democracies from within
for more than 70 years our continent has
marched towards democracy
but the gains of our long journey are
not assured
and many of us have taken democracy for
granted for too long
especially those who like me
who have never experienced what it means
to live under the fist
of an authoritarian regime
today we all see that we must fight for
our democracies
every single day
every single minute
we must protect them both from the
external threats they face
but also from the vice that corrode them
from within
it is my commission's duty and the most
noble role to protect the rule of law
so let me assure you
we will keep insisting on judicial
independence
and we will make sure that we protect
our budget through the conditionality
mechanism
and today i would like to focus on
corruption with all its faces
the face of foreign agents trying to
influence
our political system
the face of shady companies or
foundations abusing public money
if we want to be credible when we ask
candidate countries
to strengthen their democracies
we must also eradicate
corruption at home
and this
and this is why in the coming year the
commission will present measures to
update our legislative framework for
fighting corruption
we will raise standards on offenses such
as
illicit enrichment
trafficking in influence
abuse of power beyond the more classic
offenses such as bribery
and we will also propose to include
corruption
in our human rights sanctions regime
our new tool to protect our values
abroad
honourable members of founders
only meant to lay the first stone of
this democracy
they always thought that future
generation would complete their work and
that's true we have to do that it's an
ongoing process
democracy has not gone out of fashion
but it must update itself
in order to keep improving people's
lives
you will remember these words
these are the words of our friend david
zasoli
a great european
democracy has not gone out of fashion
but it must update itself in order to
keep improving people's lives
david sausali thought that europe should
always look for new horizons
and through the adversity of these times
we have started to see
what our new horizon might be
a braver union
close to its people in times of needs
bolder in responding to historic
challenges and the daily concerns of our
european
and to work at their site when they deal
with the big trials of life
this is why the conference on the future
of europe was so important it was a
sneak peek of a different kind of
citizens engagement well beyond election
day
and after europe listened to its
citizens voice we now need to deliver
the citizens panels
that were central to the conference
will now become a regular feature of our
democratic life
and in the letter of intent that i have
sent to i have outlined a number of
proposals for the year ahead that stem
from the conference of a conference on
the future
they include for example a new
initiative
on mental health
we should take much better care
of our friends and partners and be loved
ones
and for many who are burdened with
anxiety
and who are lost
appropriate
accessible accessible that's so
important and affordable support
can be life-saving we know that this
support is not there today excessive
affordable and appropriate support
so we have to make sure with proposals
on mental health that we really improve
in this subject it is for some of our
fellow europeans life-saving
honourable members
democratic institutions must constantly
gain and regain the citizens trust
just like europeans did
when millions of ukrainians come
knocking on their door
what we saw
wasn't is
europe at its best
a union of determination and solidarity
but this determination and drive for
solidarity
is still missing
in our migration debate
our actions towards ukrainian refugees
must not be an exception
they can be a blueprint for going
forward
we need fair and quick procedures
a system that is crisis proof
and quick to deploy
and a permanent and legally binding
mechanism that ensures
solidarity
and at the same time we need effective
control of our external borders in line
with the respect of fundamental rights
i want a europe that manages migration
with dignity and respect i want to
europe where all member states take
responsibility for the challenges we all
share
i want to europe that shows solidarity
to all member states
we have progress on the pact we now have
the road map and we now need the
political will to move forward and to
match
honorable members
three weeks ago
i had an incredible opportunity of
joining
1
500 young people
from all over europe
and all over the world
that gathered in tasy
they have very different views
they come from
very different countries
they speak different languages they have
different backgrounds
and yet
there's something that connects them
they share set of values and ideals
they believe in these values they are
determined to reach them
they are passionate about something that
is larger than themselves
and this generation is a phenomenal
generation it's a generation of dreamers
and makers
and in my last state of the union
i told you that i would like europe to
look more like these young people
we should put their aspirations
at the heart of everything we do
and the place for this
is in our founding treaties
every action that our union takes should
be inspired by a very simple principle
that we should do no harm to our
children's future
and that we should leave the world a
better place for the next generation
and therefore honorable members
i believe that it is time to enshrine
solidarity between generations
in our treaties
it is time to renew the european promise
and we also need to improve the way we
do things and the way we decide things
some might say it's not the right time
but if we are serious about preparing
for the world of tomorrow
we must be able to act on the things
that matter the most for people and as
we are serious about a larger union we
also have to be serious about reform
so as this parliament has called for
i believe the moment has arrived for
european convention
honorable members
they say
light shines brightest in the dark
and that was certainly true for the
women and the children fleeing russia's
bombs
they fled
a country at war
filled with sadness for what may lie
ahead
but they were received with open hearts
and open arms
by many many citizens like magdalena
two selfless young women from poland
as soon as they heard about trains full
of refugees
they rushed to the warsaw central
station
they started to organize they set up a
tent to assist as many people as
possible
they reached out to supermarket chains
for food and to local authorities to
organize buses to hospitality centers in
a matter of days they gathered 3 000
volunteers to welcome refugees 24 7.
honorable members
magdalena and agneshka are here with us
today
please stand up
magdalena stand up
stand up
their stories about everything our union
stands and strives for
it is story of heart character and
solidarity they showed everyone
what europeans can achieve when we rally
around a common cause
this is europe spirit a union that
stands strong together
a union that prevails together long live
europe thank you
[Applause]
thank you
very much dear president yeah ursula i
now move
to the reactions by
the political groups starting with the
leader of the epp group mumford brother
but i'm president of the european
parliament madame president of the
european commission adam silenski
czech presidency dear colleagues